[Musica]
buonasera 129.000 a che cosa corrisponde
questo numero questo numero corrisponde
a una semplice ricerca su google su un
motore di ricerca più famoso del mondo
se inserite effetti dello smog sulla
salute riescono in pochissimi secondi
129.000 risultati e il problema era già
ben conosciuto negli anni 80 quando vi
ricorderete o'shea forse lì forse alcuni
si ricordano uscì il famoso film blade
runner di ridley scott era ambientato in
una los angeles distopica e affollata
piena di persone e anche sostanzialmente
chiusa dallo smog da una bolla di smog
che non consentiva alle persone nel film
di vedere il sole e dove pioveva
costantemente senza bisogno di
richiamarci alla fantascienza le
immagini che vedete alle mie spalle
riguardano un ingorgo stradale in cina
che è durato nove giorni vi immaginate
rimanere bloccati nel traffico per nove
giorni infatti come vedete dalle foto le
persone si erano organizzati venivano
portati viveri sono stati creati dei
bagni le persone si lavavano il traffico
e disordine il traffico è un grossissimo
problema e non si risolve costruendo
nuove strade ed è un concetto che già
negli anni trenta rober moses famoso
costruttore della città di new york che
aveva chiarissimo
ogni volta che costruisca una nuova
strada dopo cinque minuti questa strada
è invasa dal traffico quindi non
risolviamo il problema del traffico
semplicemente costruendo nuove strade
oggi poi siamo in un'epoca in cui in
realtà tutto si rimpicciolisce non
andiamo verso l'opulenza andiamo verso
il rigore se vi ricordate qualche anno
fa cosa significava avere una collezione
musicale di cd o dlp e quanto spazio ci
voleva per tenere in casa gli lp e cd
oggi è tutto ridotto in un piccolissimo
strumento
così come oggi abbiamo in mano tutti uno
smartphone all'interno del quale la
tecnologia ci consente di fare cose che
prima non erano assolutamente
prevedibili e ovviamente non si poteva
pensare di realizzarle solo tramite un
piccolo strumento chiamato smartphone
oggi siamo in una dimensione in cui less
is more che cosa significa significa che
il meno è il più
non dobbiamo certo cercare di creare
qualcosa che stravolga al sistema ma
dobbiamo con quello che abbiamo
riuscire a trovare l'equilibrio trovare
un modo per mettere ordine al disordine
perché c'è un concetto molto importante
da tenere presente quando si parla di
traffico il traffico non è un fenomeno
lineare
cosa vuol dire che il traffico non è un
fenomeno lineare significa che il
traffico ci corrisponde perché voi
sapete benissimo che tutti i giorni
facciamo dei percorsi fissi ma facciamo
anche dei percorsi che non abbiamo mai
fatto quindi certo tutti i giorni noi
vediamo le città che la mattina vengono
invase di macchine in entrata e la sera
le macchine escono per tornare a casa e
si crea quindi un movimento di questo
genere come un polmone o un cuore ma poi
ci sono anche tutti gli altri movimenti
erratici che a seconda della giornata
noi facciamo perché abbiamo bisogno di
muoverci
quindi il traffico è un fenomeno che
riguarda tutti da cui nessuno di noi è
esente
e per di più vogliamo sempre muoverci in
un'infinità di modi diversi
un giorno preferisco usare la bicicletta
un giorno preferisco usare il motorino
un giorno preferisco spostarmi in
macchina o piove e mi devo spostare in
macchina ci sono più persone che devono
venire in macchina con me quindi abbiamo
sempre bisogno di muoverci in maniera
diversa e il nostro rapporto con la
mobilità si estrinseca in tre modi
fondamentalmente diversi il primo modo
emozionale perché abbiamo un rapporto
emozionale con la mobilità perché
muoversi significa essere liberi
io posso pensare di uscire di casa e di
andare dove voglio
quindi sono libero ed è importante per
me mantenere questo rapporto emozionale
e riuscire a pensare che posso muovermi
liberamente perché questo corrisponde a
quello che io voglio fare per il nostro
rapporto con la mobilità e anche
condizionato da un altro elemento
culturale significa che spesso il nostro
modo di muoversi dipende dall'ambiente
circostante dalla nostra cultura dal
come siamo stati abituati
se avete bisogno ad esempio che l'italia
è un paese dove c'è un numero molto
molto alto di vetture per abitante siamo
sopra la media europea abbiamo circa 60
vetture ogni 100 abitanti la media
europea è sotto le 50 vetture
quindi c'è anche un tema culturale
connesso alla mobilità poi su questo vi
dirò una cosa abbastanza sorprendente ma
dovete tener a mente che siamo comunque
sempre condizionati e poi abbiamo un
altro modo di interagire con la mobilità
che aspira aspirazionale ciascuno di noi
ogni giorno pensa che quel senso unico
sia fatto male che quella rotatoria non
sia nel posto giusto che quel semaforo
non duri abbastanza che quella
attraversamento pedonale non sia messo
nel posto corretto un po la stessa cosa
che noi italiani soprattutto facciamo
col calcio no dopo una partita di calcio
siamo tutti bravissimi a dire potevano
fare così potevano fare in quest'altro
modo avrebbero dovuto fare stesso
discorso con la mobilità non è purtroppo
così semplice anche perché quello che
noi cerchiamo oggi è comunque di vivere
tutti nelle città
oggi ci sono 3,5 milioni miliardi di
persone che vivono nelle città il 60 el
80 per cento delle risorse vengono
consumate direttamente dalle città due
terzi della popolazione mondiale entro
il 2030 vivrà nelle città
questo non agevola come potete
immaginare è questo il trend che vedete
che accadrà nei prossimi anni
nel 1970 al 30 per cento delle persone
vivevano nelle città nel 2014 54
nel 2050 il 66 per cento delle persone
vivranno nelle città non semplice da
gestire è un movimento costante in
crescita che porta le persone ovviamente
a concentrarsi in un unico posto perché
è più facile l'accesso ai servizi
poi cosa è successo negli ultimi anni la
crisi economica che come sapete ha
portato tante cose negative ha portato
anche qualcosa di positivo si è
sviluppata negli ultimi anni la sharing
economy e anche in italia la sharing
economy sta dando grandi frutti e grandi
risultati la sharing economy che
significa semplicemente passare dal
possesso di un bene all'accesso allo
stesso bene non è più necessario che io
sia il proprietario di quel bene perché
mi interessa fruire di quel bene solo
per un tempo preciso e stabilito e non
ho bisogno di averlo posso accedere a
quel bene senza avere bisogno di
possederlo la sharing economy ha avuto
impatti diretti in tre settori
fondamentali l'ospitalità nel senso
appunto gli alberghi le case diffuse
come siete tutti i fenomeni famosi come
airbnb nella mobilità e nel lavoro
diffuso perché si sono create nuove
professioni nella mobilità ha avuto un
impatto molto forte e anche in italia
che appunto come vi dicevo prima è tra i
paesi in cui c'è un alto numero di auto
di proprietà per abitante in realtà ha
trovato un terreno estremamente fertile
nonostante fosse l'ultimo paese in cui a
livello europeo si pensava di investire
nella sharing economy
in realtà gli utenti di sharing economy
quindi sharing mobility sono tantissimi
e in italia ci sono dei casi di grande
successo
questo come vedete un grafico che vi
dice quanto si sta diffondendo lasciare
in lasciare in mobilità entro il 2020 ci
saranno 15,6 milioni di persone che
utilizzeranno soltanto veicoli in
condivisione
e non sceglierò più non sceglieranno più
di comprare un'auto privata oltre alla
sharing economy
oggi ci troviamo di fronte a un altro
fenomeno molto importante che è l'app
economy dentro il vostro smartphone
avete tutte le app possibili e
immaginabili quelle che tutti conosciamo
ovviamente e ci sono anche tantissime
app che danno accesso a sistemi di
mobilità quindi oggi lo smartphone
diventa un accesso diretto al mondo
della mobilità oltre che a tantissime
altre funzioni di cui abbiamo bisogno
tutti i giorni
questo tipo di economia è molto
importante perché è in crescita
incredibile
si valuta che entro il 2021 6,3 trilioni
di dollari gireranno intorno alla asp
economy gli utenti cresceranno dagli
attuali 3,4 milioni di persone a 6,3
milioni miliardi di persone
ma la cosa pazzesca il tempo speso sulle
app il tempo che spenderemo sulle app
crescerà fino a 3,5 trilioni di ore nel
quindi oggi in realtà la mobilità è uno
strumento attraverso il quale noi
possiamo governare
il disordine governare il disordine e il
disordine è il traffico
abbiamo accesso oggi ha delle buone
pratiche abbiamo accesso a sistemi che
ci consentono di utilizzare attraverso
lo smartphone più tipologie di mobilità
anche intero in maniera interoperabile
che cosa significa significa che io
posso usare un'applicazione che mi porta
da abi e poi con un altro strumento
muovermi sempre tramite un'altra
applicazione e magari fare lo
spostamento di lunga percorrenza col
treno e queste sono le formule che oggi
ci consentono di pensare a un futuro
futuro migliore
oggi una delle tendenze che si sta
sviluppando si chiama mas mobility esa
services
ci sono aziende
immaginate che stanno investendo
tantissimo per far crescere la mobilità
come un servizio e non più come qualcosa
che io devo possedere per muovermi ma
come un servizio a cui posso accedere
quindi oggi ci sono le soluzioni ce ne
saranno sempre di più il mondo si sta
muovendo in questa direzione ma quello
che dobbiamo sempre tenere presente è
che dobbiamo sempre metterci il nostro
impegno e la nostra volontà perché
abbiamo un pianeta solo finito quello
non ce ne saranno più
grazie mille
[Applauso]
[Musica]